when somebody dies and they're not found
after a course of time the body once it
sets into rigor mortis and comes out of
rigor mortis it starts to decompose them
gases inside the stomach will eventually
expand causing the body to balloon and
eventually burst at different offices
the body will literally decompose it
will start to fall into pieces and turn
to mush if you can imagine pouring a
quart of oil on a floor how it would
spread out that's kind of what a bodily
fluid will do body she was laying this
way
going into a home where somebody's
passed away of course you're gonna be
dealing with all types of bodily fluids
blood saliva spinal fluid cerebral fluid
not knowing who the person was not
knowing the history on them you can
counter anything from hepatitis to
Clostridium difficile you're gonna be
worried about viruses and bacteria or
disease that may be in the home or
around the biological matter itself
we're concerned about everything you
never know what you're gonna get at any
home I mean you can pick up one of those
flesh-eating bacterias in any house
which is why we're wearing gloves in any
five rated masks CT doggles things like
that we use a product it has a hydrogen
peroxide solution based in it we will
spray that or apply that to certain
areas that we suspect are affected by my
logical manner well confirm it in his
bio and then it'll either be cleaned if
it's something that can't be clean if
it's a porous surface or something
that's semi permeable where the bio was
so into it then our recommendation is to
remove it we have had to remove portions
of structure to remove biological matter
I've had to remove bathtubs
she walked baseboards ceiling tiles
carpet padding subfloor so yeah there
are some some pretty significant dangers
to the job but with proper protection
and training anything can be tackled
I encounter a lot of families that are
distraught going into a situation like
that and being sympathetic and
empathetic as well towards families
putting them at ease and going in and
taking care of the situation at hand
little were there is really what drives
me to do this to help people
you